another week our last day in Westeros
for the year I'm gonna miss these videos
I truly mean that too it's been nothing
but enjoyable doing videos on House of
the dragon and that's because the
conversation in the comments section
with you the audience the viewers so
thank you for that and before we get
started yes I do want to thank the
sponsor of this video this video is
brought to you by the ridge the ridge
ball is the Sleek minimalist alternative
to the wallet holds up to 12 cars inside
room for cash on the back comes in over
30 colors they're bound to have the
style that fits you and because it's
small and minimalist it's not limited to
going just in the back pocket like a
conventional wallet go in the back
pocket front pocket jacket pocket like a
billfold be classic and say goodbye to
the keyrings got the ridge key case
holds up to seven keys which is more
than I need I think it has a pocket
knife for your keys you can even clip
your car keys on the end so click the
link below go to ridge.com John's enter
promo code John's get yourself 10 off
your order and now I'm going to give you
that spoiler warning for this episode
and just to be safe for this season I
don't know if I'm in a conversationally
backtrack too much to talk about the
season as a whole just stick to this
episode but better safe than sorry this
episode as the season one finale did
leave me with that feeling of I really
wanted to see more this episode felt
really short but that is the old adage
of good entertainment leave the audience
wanting more and I will say by the end
of this the board is set so whereas the
previous episode of House of the Dragon
was all about the power vacuum in King's
Landing after the King was dead it was
like okay
um let's Seize the Throne so all these
years of scheming and meetings and
meetings that the queen didn't know
about to get the Queen's kid on the
throat it was all it was all coming to
effect but Runner was nowhere there she
was nowhere in the episode now we get to
see renera as she finds out her father
is dead I really liked rayniss in this
episode she's the one who informs renera
that her father was dead and she's the
one who kind of just [ __ ] on the entire
ceremony and was like I could breathe
fire on you with my dual I can't my
dragon could but as we all know that
would melt the throne and the throne
isn't melted in the future so off I fly
it's easy to be like oh why didn't she
just blast the king but that's what I
like about the world of Westeros it is a
world built around rules she could do
that but she would definitely be a
fugitive she would be a criminal just
murdered the king but as this episode
showed us dragons can kind of do their
thing and do what they want so she could
always just blame it on a dragon there
is that I'm not saying that defense
would fly but it would be a defense that
she could try but I liked how she was
kind of she felt more like Damon
Targaryen for this episode you know she
was the leaner she was the one always
leaning against the wall and listening
to what everyone was saying the wild
card in the room kind of feeling I
always got that with Damon but in this
episode I got it with her I like that
Damon's on the war path he's like okay
and then we go here and we try to get
these families and and [ __ ] them up and
burn them to the ground yes you had a
question that war room scene around the
table was very I was like this is Game
of Thrones season two style right here
that's what I mean when I say I like
this show because it takes me back to
the early days of Game of Thrones and
what I liked about Game of Thrones but
this time around for whatever fight is
coming
it is at least addressed in the room
that well we do have dragons
there's that look we've all played
tactics games we've all played Fire
Emblem we all know that those Riders
very advantageous Army right there let's
just hope the other side doesn't have
archers
then you're kind of [ __ ] but in this
world I feel like archers aren't going
to do dick I do like how we see the
quality of rhaenera's character a
renera's character as a leader as a
queen in this episode where she feels
that her duty is to the people of the
land so let's try to avoid Bloodshed
Damon's over there all like but but
it's like you remember that time I was
dragging half a body from that bad case
of crab out of that cave I did that I'm
ready for this sea snakes alive which is
great you know he's been gone for a
couple episodes a couple episodes for us
six years or so for the people in the
show for the characters that's where you
get the feeling of people are going to
have to work together and put their
grievances aside for the common goal at
least until the common goals met maybe
then they'll square up maybe they'll
square off before that goal is met I
don't know he was like yeah where's
Damon he's at the store
right that's very convenient that birth
scene was rough because renero starts
going into labor I use birth Loosely
more of a miscarriage scene really point
is talk about compounding the [ __ ]
in your life she just found out her dad
died and that her former friend has
basically usurped the throne by putting
her son on the throne and then people
she thought were her allies just kind of
side with that also she goes into labor
and her baby's born dead the big thing
in this episode it might feel that way
because it was the last thing in this
episode was renera's kids go out there
as Messengers he lands in this place to
go talk to the leader of this place so
we can be like hey you want to join our
cause I got nothing to give you I'm just
pretty please I know I'm in the distance
you see what I can only describe as a
dragon that looks as big as the world
serpent in God of War which I loved it
was like oh that dragon is enormous
granted I mean we saw a kid have to
climb a ladder onto the dragon some
episodes back something about the scale
of that him in the background and that
lightning was like oh that's a it's a
very big dragon and sure enough eye
patch serial killer face is already
there talking to this dude when I was
kid's like I got nothing to prom I'm
just you know I just figured I'd be nice
and ask for you don't want her you're
not biting this really isn't okay you
don't care okay well I should have
should have known that if the throne if
the queen had any brains whatsoever
that she'd be out there rallying the
Army like we're trying to do I
too little too late too little
okay bye Eamonn was like wait
you give me your eye something he has
asked for in the past and something he
will continue to well he might not ask
after this episode but he's just
he really wants an eye for an eye and
has for years and it basically ends with
his dragonfly this kid just bails on his
Dragon so what's his cat and mouse game
among the clouds between a dragon and
the dragon and among this cat and mouse
game out of nowhere dead and that's that
and you really get the feeling it was
that Eamon wanted to mess with this kid
and just freak him out a bit he didn't
want him to die I can only describe it
as imagine that scene in Karate Kid
where Johnny and his friends are beating
up Daniel and when Daniel hits that
fence imagine the fence got struck by
lightning at that moment and Daniels
just died and Johnny was like oh my God
I just killed him and imagine Daniel was
the son of the leader of a country or
something that's that's where we are it
was a very big oops that's going to lead
to very big things because renera Mama
Bear Mama Dragon did not look happy it's
quite possible very quickly that moral
conundrum of maybe we shouldn't have
Bloodshed because think of the the
people that that doesn't always stay in
focus when a kid gets eaten by a dragon
all this really showed something
compelling to me was that dragons just
gonna do their thing Dragon Riders have
no more control over dragons than
Sailors have control over the sea you
can see the look on eamon's face right
there though he was like
oops my mom is gonna be so mad
watch that the wall is taking
applications
fantastic on my way you know this where
the episode ends with renera having us
look in her eyes like
[ __ ] them cut to credits and House of
the Dragons been a fun watch it's
actually been a lot of fun talking about
the episodes every week it was the show
that I had to look forward to like oh
hey it's Sunday sometimes I got these
videos to you a little later like Monday
but at no point was I watching the
episodes being like Ugh you know it was
never a chore anytime it came on it was
locked in until end credits I think it's
worth a watch I know the final season of
Game of Thrones left a bad taste in a
lot of people's mouths I get that but
that's probably part of why I've enjoyed
House of the Dragon it washes a part of
that taste out of my mouth also House of
the Dragon has different showrunners
than Game of Thrones had so there is
that I say that because I've seen the
comment of lag I'm not watching House of
the Dragon they ruined Game of Thrones
well they didn't the show Runners of
House of the Dragon did not do that it
only seems like they're trying to bring
what they love about west roast to the
screen for our entertainment I
appreciate that all in all I thought
season one and House of the Dragon was
solid great acting compelling characters
solid tension the world of Westeros feel
feels smaller maybe I should phrase it
it feels more intimate in House of the
Dragon than it felt in Game of Thrones
because you're not dividing equal time
among all the houses it's a more
personal look into the house of the
Dragon the targaryens but it still
maintains the essence of the fact that
there is still a Game of Thrones being
played and that game within the
Targaryen family has ramped up to the
point where now it's War I thought it
was great all right so House of the
Dragon the season one finale have you
seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]